[Music]
foreign
what's up YouTube I'm back talking about
the newly announced the Sigma 18 to 50 F
2.8 DC DN lens for the Sony e-mount and
element Alliance now this is an aps-c
lens so for you Sony a6000 users zve10
users this lens is for you element users
uh if you want to use it for video you
don't have a lot of options in the aps-c
format I mean for like I could get the
CL and the tl2 but those are primarily
photographers cameras then video cameras
so I would say for Sony users you're
going to be able to utilize the hybrid
functionality out of this lens more so
than the L Mount users anyway we are
recording this entire video with the 18
to 50 and up 2.8 DC DN lens so you'll
see how it focuses you're going to see
how razor sharp it is and we're shooting
at F 2.8 so you're getting real world
performance how it works for video but
before we kick things off I do want to
thank Sigma Singapore for uh providing
the lenses for this review having said
that these are my thoughts and my
thoughts only so let's talk about what's
inside of this lens you got 13 elements
in 10 groups one sld element and three
as spherical elements that's right three
spherical elements now this is an 18 to
50 silver full-frame users out there
this is about 28 to 75 they're about so
this is a standard zoom lens Sigma is
touting this as the world's lightest and
smallest standard zoom lens at F 2.8 is
it I don't know I I mean I'm guessing
they're doing their measurements out
there I'm not going to argue with them
but it does come in a 290 grams so it's
pretty lightweight and it's pretty
compact as you can see right here this
is going to fit really nicely into
someone's camera bag now in terms of the
optical performance out of this lens I
mean as I mentioned three historical
elements this is a well-corrected lens
it is sharp at 2.8 wide open it looks
fantastic I'm going to show you some
images in just a bit to give you some a
real world performance in nighttime
photography how it performs and how it
focuses but it did a fantastic job
outside of that though I mean this is a
very nice lens for videographers out
there I think this is primarily what
Sigma is hitting with this lens is
because a lot of people are moving to
video and they want a smaller
lightweight camera system and a 6000
series as I mentioned or a zve E10 is
going to be a great option for you out
there now is it going to be a vlogger's
lens well at 18 millimeters I think it's
still a little bit tricky for aps-c I
mean depends on your crop if you don't
have a crop you might be able to pull it
off 16 usually is safer but you can
definitely do it if you have a some sort
of let's say tripod or a monopod or
something that you can hold in your hand
to give you some extra distance I think
you're going to be fine for vlogging but
if you put on a tripod you're gonna be
fine no issues at all just like what I'm
doing right here anyway for you
l-mountain users out there I would say
that as mentioned CL tl2 photographer's
lens if you need a good standard zoom
lens at F 2.8 because Leica likes to do
that variable aperture with the zoom
lenses I would say this might be a very
good option to take on a trip with you
it performs great I mean on the L Mount
I tried on the sigma FPL because I don't
have an aps-c uh L Mount camera but it
performed great on the uh Sigma FPL and
yeah on the Sony cameras it performs
beautifully as well in terms of Auto
focusing speed it's right up there with
Native lenses from the other companies
so I mean sigma's really built a very
nice lens there's really nothing for me
to complain about this probably my
shortest review I've ever done on a lens
because this lens is that good there's
really no downsides to do it I mean if
you need a lens in this vocal range I
would say pick this one up
um if you don't then you don't I mean
there's another option out there the
Tamron the 17 to 70 and that's also a
very good lens I think the sigma the 18
to 50 just depends what you need I mean
they're both very comparable in terms of
their Optical qualities out there uh
some people have a preference for Sigma
some people have a preference for Tamron
I don't have both to really compare them
against each other but I will say based
on my test with the 1770 from Tamron and
the 18 to 50 here they're neck and neck
so you really can't go wrong either way
but I would say that the sigma has to me
has a little bit better build quality
just slightly on the has the edge on the
build quality and I think with the
Optics inside of it I think they've done
a pretty damn good job so anyway I'm
going to show you a bit of a photo
montage of images I've taken with this
lens so enjoy I'll come back with my
final thoughts
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so as you can tell by the images the
lens is tack sharp even at F 2.8 it's
designed to be sharp wide open and sigma
has nailed it with this lens I really
don't have any complaints guys as I told
you this is going to be a very short
lens review because the Optics as you're
seeing from video are really good I'm
sharp I'm in Focus this entire time the
images out of this lens are really nice
for photographers out there so if you
need this focal range I would say
definitely check it out there are some
other options out there that are really
close to this but I would say Sigma with
the Optics that they've been putting in
their lenses as of late I would say this
is one I would really consider if I have
an aps-c camera build quality is nice
it's compact it's lightweight it's great
for travel when we can travel again for
those who are still you know uh limited
as we are here in Singapore but for
those of you in America or Europe that
are traveling abound then this might be
a great lens to pick up anyway those are
my thoughts on the sigma 1850 F 2.8 DC
DN lens if you like this video uh
subscribe to the channel as well we have
a lot of great content coming up with
that take care stay safe and I'll chat
to you soon bye
[Music]